le printemps du Bourger avec dans les
coulisses de cette grande fête de
l'aéronautique une apre bataille
commerciale entre les grands
constructeurs notamment la firme
américaine Boeing et le groupe européen
Airbus les deux rivaux vont bientôt
s'affronter sur les chronau des Jumbo de
6800 voire 1000 places par avion
reportage Patrick estter et Patrick
vois ce pourrait être le salon de l'auto
mais nous sommes dans l'allée des
chalets au Bourget ces grosses voitures
appartiennent à la petite communauté
d'hommees qui dans un certain confort
discute d'affaires portant sur des
milliards de francs l'avenir de
l'aéronautique civile ici on achète et
on vend des avions ainsi l'Airbus 340
cadri réacteur long courrier concurrent
direct du Boeing 747 n'a pas encore volé
et déjà 200 exemplaires ont été
commandés malgré la chute du trafic
aérien durant la guerre du Golf les
affaires ne vont pas trop mal pour les
constructeurs côté compagnie aérienne le
trafic revient et le trafic revient on
va voir une accroissance dans pendant
cette année à peu près 1 % par rapport à
4 ou 5 % prévu mais au moins ça remonte
mais au fait à qui profitent les progrès
techniques les nouveaux moteurs plus
puissant et plus économe en carburant
les avions toujours plus gros tel ce
projet d'Airbus à double étage de rangée
de Huot la 2000 qui pourrait emporter
750 ou 800 passagers dès la fin du
siècle alors qui bénéficiera la per
technologique aux compagnies ou au
passagers le transport aérien c'est
service une service qui marche si le
passager est
satisfait ce que représente les avances
de technologie c'est de permettre de
réduire les coûts d'exploitation au
profit du passager ça ne veut pas dire
nécessairement que les tarifs vont
réduire mais au MO les tarifs vont
pasugmenteréfort espérer que les
passagers voyageront sans avoir les
genoux sous le menton les hommes
d'affaires pourront continuer à
travailler en vol dès l'année prochaine
ils auront la possibilité de téléphoner
et d'expédier des fax enfin l'équipage
aura droit aux couchettes et dans 5 ou
10 ans certains passagers également